Devin any tips for managing people for
someone that maybe has rusty people
skills yeah if someone is having trouble
managing someone to me the best advice I
ever got was listen I patience and then
find a resolution right away I think a
lot of people try to focus on what the
problem is so there's an issue at that
point in time all i care about is fixing
the problem find that resolution so we
can keep moving forward once we're back
on track moving forward then I'll go
back to find out how do we get to that
point to where it's something didn't
happen the way it should have and once I
started taking that attitude it kind of
helped it kind of helped me keep things
running running smooth just because you
know we're human you know we can get
caught up in the moment and spending 15
20 minutes you know why did you do this
and why'd you do that and how this
happen is doesn't help anything let's
fix it then we'll go back and make the
adjustment and if we have to keep making
the adjustment because that person keeps
messing up then unfortunately we have to
let that person go which is never fun
but he's all right i rather educate
someone and help make them better at
what they do versus just going now you
screwed up once you're done so sounds
like listen patients and fix it yeah
okay I like that yeah that's great don't
worry about how it got there right
because some people just really did they
really just make a mistake and they just
are unaware and some people just screw
up every once in a while and we all do
you know we all make mistakes it's just
that the mistake keeps happening over
over again by the same person that's
when it becomes a problem
you